to be able to bring enough back we now
have to go further and further out
there's our traditional fishing grounds
no longer productive keith is one of
millions of people who make their living
from the sea is like the the moment of
anxiety am I gonna catch I'm gonna catch
enough am I gonna be to keep in the crew
and like many others he's sounding an
alarm we used to see out from six to
eight days and would get significant
cash to cover expenses significant
income to take home but now to be able
to bring the same amount of money home
we have to stay out till double the
number of days so this is jus mainly I
would say to overfishing the Seychelles
like many small developing economies has
sold the rights to fish in its waters to
pose for the European Union what is a
man from the country doing here
girly or a small boss went to fish over
there now they're small boats becoming
bigger boat like this this is funny
friends modern fishing techniques posted
by sonar some computers have allowed
industrial operations to gain me a
chance to take the tuna chute in the net
here and take this tuna easy for me how
many hours is this process hours just
minutes minutes past in recent years the
statistics have revealed something
disturbing its me not to go to faith in
fishing circles for as long as anyone
can remember that there was a pretty
much infinite number of fish in the sea
that however big the population got
you'd always be able to find fish for
the table and for most of the 20th
century that was pretty much born out by
the numbers decade after decade the
number of fish being caught rows and
rows but in recent years something
changed and the fish catchers started
for the first time in history to fall
for some economists it's an illustration
of an old theory the tragedy of the
Commons we all own the oceans and yet
none of us does it's common property and
there's nothing to stop each of us
individually doing what we want with it
on mass that has serious consequences so
serious that even institutions like the
Bank of England are starting to count
the cost
it's individual irrational behavior the
cost of having another cow on the on the
common pasture for the individual it's a
net benefit but for the for the group
that can lead to over grazing and and
and that cost the extra fishing trawler
in the high seas again individual
benefit for the world overfishing for
the potential extinction of some fish
stocks all these other feedbacks so
those are market failures
but those market failures are
exacerbated by a growing population and
unprecedented demand around the world
for fish this tuna cannery in the
Seychelles produces 1.6 million cans a
day much of it going to the UK and
Europe we are talking about 60% of fish
stocks being overfished so this means
that we are putting a extremely heavy
pressure on our marine resources some
academics think we are running out of
time
they say that unless something changes
and soon humankind will have effectively
exhausted the oceans of fish by 2050 at
Conway Sky News